there's been a shooting in Istanbul
which has left three people wounded and
two attackers dead a man and a woman
opened fire at a police checkpoint in
front of a courthouse two of those
injured were police officers CM kavogu
join us now from eskander and in Tura
what more do we know about what's
happened well the number of the Wounded
increased to six three of them are
police officers and three of them are
civilians and as far as we know what uh
interior Minister Ali Araya posted on
his social media the attack the
attempted attack in his words uh was
done by the uh revolutionary people's uh
Liberation Front DH KPC uh which is a
far-left
organization that is deemed as a
terrorist group in Turkey H so far what
we know is that the investigation has
been launched and uh and the police is
trying to find what is behind this and
why this attack uh was planned but in
2015 the same organization targeted a
prosecutor in Istanbul who was uh
working on a file that was related to
gazi protest uh of 2013 and they took
that prosecutor as hostage and after 6
hours of negotiation uh the the
prosecutor uh was severely injured and
he died and the attackers were also uh
killed by the security forces inside the
building so we are waiting for more
details uh to arrive uh by the
authorities back to you okay s thank you
so much for that update from tur well we
can now speak to Ahmed ker he's an
Associated Professor political science
at Hassan konju University he's joining
us from gazan thanks for your time with
us on Al jazer what are you hearing
about this attack
sir uh thank you for having me uh as
mentioned by sanm uh already the attack
is claimed responsibility by the
Revolutionary people's Liberation party
and front and also the minister of
interior Ali Yaya clearly declared that
the two killed terrorists are belonging
to this organization when we look at the
background of this organization uh this
is a ter terrorist organization included
in the international terrorist
organizations list as well founded in
1994 by dun karates which has a Marxist
list ideology
when we look at the terrorist attacks
conducted by this all Terror
organization they usually Target the
governmental officials bureaucrats
police officers Military Officers Etc
and they aim at changing the overall
regime and the system uh to a communist
Marxist list regime so they usually
cooperate with pkk PID terrorist
organization as well in their attacks
especially in the Eastern part what
could be behind what what what do you
think could be behind this particular
attack that happened in front of a
courthouse we understand from cinim that
six people have been wounded and the two
attackers have been
killed uh there might be several uh of
course uh intentions uh first of all the
upcoming local elections so the first
aim of the terrorist organizations is
creating chaotic enir
especially before the elections to
prevent the free elections especially
isul is very important a great
Metropolitan to affect the results of
these uh elections it might be one of
the reasons uh the second uh is um as
you know uh there is another uh ongoing
uh challenge especially between the high
level courts between the uh Supreme uh
court and the uh other court mechanisms
uh regarding uh justice system so to
increase the tension regarding the
justly uh effective implementation of
the justice system and uh to create aair
in the public is the main aim objective
of the terrorist organization in
conducting this event iting right
obviously I mean we will await to see
what the results of the
investigation uh is the the uh there is
an ongoing investigation according to
our correspondent Cinema from
Istanbul um but uh how do you expect the
government to
respond uh of course uh first of all uh
by using the network uh and
communication uh systems uh of these
terrorists I think uh the investigators
will try to reach uh who is uh behind uh
the key point at this attack who
targeted who collected intelligence and
I think we can expect more uh arrestment
uh after this one uh because uh the
connections and network uh including all
the people especially located in stanbul
and elsewhere will be designated and uh
they will be arrested so we can see
upcoming operations Police Operations as
well all right thank you Ahmed kaser we
thank you for joining us from
Gaz thanks for having me